Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday, July 30th, 2013 and I'm back!
I missed you guys so much! But I've really had a wonderful paternity
leave. It's just so great to be home with my
family and my beautiful baby dau-
Am I...
Am I in an airport?! Dang it!
So, Hank, I'm on my way to VidCon...  *muffled airport announcement*
Oh, I can't smoke?
I can't smoke inside of a public building?
That's a shock! Can I snort heroin? Oh?
I'm not allowed to snort heroin either?
What is this, an airport or a monastery? Right, but before I was in this airport on my
way to VidCon, I spent the last month
with my family on the United States'
third coast: Lake Michigan.
There was the beautiful water and
astonishing sunsets and sometimes people
would pretend to have a war to celebrate
America's independence.
There were also a lot of Nerdfighters there
on the coast of Lake Michigan, although I
never met them
until and unless I removed my shirt at
the beach, at which point inevitably
someone would walk up to me and be like, "Are
you John Green?" And I would be like...
"*nervous mumble* yesss..."
Right, I want to tell you about a funny thing that happened, but I have to go get on the plane
so I'll tell you in California. MOVIE....
MAGIC! That joke was six hours in the
making. So Hank, as a preface to the story
you have to understand that while my son
Henry is very bright, he is also three
and a half years old. So he rarely says
things that surprise me because, you know,
like, I taught him all the words he knows.
Okay, so when we first get to Michigan
Henry and I go down to the beach and
we're digging holes, you know,
looking for treasure. And he says, "Daddy, I
wanna dig a big hole! I want to dig
all the way the tippy tippy bottom!"
(which, of course, is the opposite of the tippy tippy top).
And I said, "Yeah! Let's keep digging!" and Henry said, "Daddy, this is
so fun!" And I said, "I know!", and then he
said, "Daddy, do you know who likes digging holes?"
And I said, "No. Who?" and he looked at me and
he said, "Germans".
Okay, so when Henry was one we lived for a
little while in the Netherlands while I
was researching The Fault in Our Stars. And we kept
running into Dutch people
who would tell us that they didn't
really think that highly of Germans.
And I would be like, "Oh, yeah, because of the
Second World War and the Occupation
and everything." And they would say "No, no, no, that's
all water under the bridge. It's because
they dig holes in our beaches."
This happened like six different times, and Sarah and I
would always comment upon it,
apparently in the presence of Henry. And
then we went to a Dutch beach,
and sure enough, there were all of these
people with, like, full sized shovels
digging, like, thirty foot deep holes, and
all of them were speaking German!
And Henry, somewhere in the deep recesses
of his one-year-old brain,
remembered this, which makes me worry about
all the other things that he might
remember. Like the times during Liverpool games when I forget to use the
word "darn" and also forget to use the word
"damn".
Anyway, Hank, I bring this up for two reasons.
First: I think it is time for German
people and Dutch people to have a
constructive dialogue about the holes-
in-beaches phenomenon. And secondly: Henry
is three and a half years old and he
already has his first cultural
stereotype, hole-digging Germans.
I think that says a lot about us as
humans. Anyway, I know there's nothing
more boring than stories about other people's
kids, but whatever, they're adorable!
Okay, Hank, I just want to take a second to thank all of Nerdfighteria for being so understanding during
my paternity leave, and also to the
amazing guest hosts who made it so much fun.
Frankly, more fun than, like,
regular me. You can find links to all of their channels in the doobly-doo. Hank, thank you for this
nice hotel room. I will see you when I go
downstairs after finishing editing this. Byeeee!